thierry roy je suis le roi
je suis le roi du monde
c'est un mauvais perdant et revoir je
n'ai battu à chaque ronde codis je vis
ce quinté le visage et coupé son visage
il était tellement fatigués qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas rester debout et viennent
mais s'il avait s'il s'est dit relever
avant le compte j'en aurais encore mis
ko est descendu au ryman peut avoir sa
revanche mais il n'a aucune chance
vous avez tous vous pouvez vous retirer
maintenant je ne suis pas libre
j'ai beaucoup à faire pour aider 4
millions de noirs musulmans qui ne sont
pas encore américain livre et qui n'ont
pas réussi à avoir l'égalité la sécurité
et l'indépendance
sept ans après avoir été déchu mohammed
ali alias cassius clay est champion du
monde toutes catégories